-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show"!
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, this is fun.
Today is National
Aunt and Uncles Day.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
I love my aunts and uncles.
They've taught me so much,
like the difference between
wine drunk and beer drunk.
Hey, everyone's
talking about this.
Tonight's Mega Millions jackpot
is one of the biggest ever,
at nearly $1 billion.
If you forgot to buy a ticket,
congrats, you just won $2.
Yep, by tonight,
some lucky person
is gonna gain
millions of dollars
and hundreds of new cousins.
"Hey, happy Aunt And Uncles Day.
Remember me?"
That's right --
nearly a billion dollars.
Yeah, that kind of
money's a lot of pressure.
I mean, if you win that,
next thing you know,
you're buying Twitter
and having an affair with
the founder of Google's wife,
you know?
It's just --
It's a slippery slope.
Let's get to some news
here, guys.
As he continues to
recover from COVID,
President Biden told reporters
he's sleeping so well
that his dog had to
wake him up yesterday morning.
[ Laughter ]
And reporters responded with
a very nervous laugh.
They're like...
[ Laughs lightly ]
You know that dog was
kind of freaking out like,
"Joe? Joe? Joe? Whew."
You can tell Biden was tired,
'cause he tapped the dog's head
and told him to come back
nine minutes later.
More news from The White House.
I read that
to fight climate change,
the Biden administration
has pledged
to plant 1 billion trees.
Yep. And just
for fun, they're planting them
in the middle of Trump's
golf course at Mar-a-Lago.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Right in the middle.
Meanwhile, this morning,
Biden woke up from
his COVID fever like,
"Did I order a billion trees?"
I'm sorry. Uh, yeah? Tariq?
-Um, yeah, I had a question.
Well, are they planting
a billion seeds
or a billion trees?
Because there's a difference.
-You know what?
I don't really know.
[ Chuckles ] Yes, Tariq.
-If I had to guess,
I'd say they're planting seeds.
♪♪
-'Cause you gotta plant
the seeds to make the trees.
-And you gotta wet the seeds
to get the leaves.
-A billion trees
from a billion seeds.
-We'll be seeing green
from sea-to-sea.
-So much pollen,
can't help but sneeze.
-But that's okay,
it's fine by me.
-'Cause clean air
is what we want to see.
-To the birds and
the insects and the bumblebees.
-We'll be oh-so-happy
to enjoy that breeze.
-A billion trees
from a billion seeds?
I got one answer,
yes, please.
-♪ Seeds and trees ♪
♪ Planting the crops ♪
♪ Ready or not ♪
-"Seeds and Trees Mixtape,
2022."
[ Air horn blows ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What is going on?
-Man.
I saw that -- Guys, today,
former President Trump returned
to Washington, D.C.,
for the first time
since leaving office.
Trump said, "Well,
since I'm still the president,
it only makes sense I stop by."
Switching gears, T-Mobile
has agreed to pay its customers
$350 million in a settlement
over a massive data breach.
We actually have
their lawyer on the line
to explain their settlement.
Yeah, sir, are you there?
-Hi, Jimmy.
Thank you for having me.
"Tonight Show"...to be here.
-Sorry? This is
a massive settlement here,
so how are you feeling?
-Well, now that...settlement...
completed...
try to relax...
raspberry custard...
nipples...that hamster.
-I'm sorry. You're cutting out.
Can you say that again?
-Of course.
I was just saying now that
the settlement is completed,
I...go home...
raspberry custard...
nipples...that hamster.
-Sorry. It's still a bit choppy.
It's not really making sense.
Can you switch to Wi-Fi?
-Uh, sure, Jimmy. How's this?
Can you hear me now?
-It's much better. Thank you.
-Great.
I was just saying, now that the
settlement is completed,
I want to relax.
I think I might go home
and smear raspberry custard
on my nipples and let my
pet hamster nibble on it
until it tickles.
That usually helps me calm down.
-Alright, good luck with that.
Thank you for joining us today.
The lawyer from...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't know.
Hey, have you guys seen this?
There's an online movement of
people who want Instagram
to go back to being
a photo-sharing app
and are criticizing it
for trying to copy TikTok.
You know things
are bad when Instagram
is getting bullied on Instagram.
-Wow!
-Some TV news.
Last night on
"The Bachelorette,"
producers brought
Zach and Rachel
to a movie theater and
showed them a surprise montage
that they'd put together
for their date.
And I thought the whole thing
was a little bizarre.
Take a look. See if you see it.
♪♪
-Zach, man.
Zachary.
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Coughs ]
-Oh, my gosh. What do I do?
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You notice it was weird?
Hey, guys, get this.
A dating site for
anti-vaxxers called Unjected
had -- this is real -- had all
of its user data exposed online.
Yeah. But don't worry.
Everyone is doing their own
research on how to fix it.
Users' names, birthdays, e-mail
addresses, and home addresses
were exposed,
but on the plus side,
their data is one step closer
to herd immunity.
Hey, listen to this.
According to a new report,
the Chevy Silverado
is the most stolen vehicle
in the country.
-Ooh!
-And Chevy decided to use
this fact as a selling point
in their latest commercial.
Watch this.
-So, our Silverado is the
most stolen vehicle in America.
Well, maybe it's because of
our Duramax turbo-diesel engine.
Or maybe it's because of
our automatic emergency braking.
Or just maybe it's because
our doors don't lock,
there's no alarm system,
and you can start the truck
just by breathing
on the steering wheel.
-[ Breathes deeply ]
-Chevy Silverado --
apparently, they're free now.
-I saw that today.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, I saw a house listing
that's getting a lot of
attention for
its strange design.
Check this thing out.
-An unusual property
in Pismo Beach, California,
is attracting
a lot of attention.
The listing on Zillow could be
a record for a tree house.
It was actually a house
built around a tree.
Asking price -- $3.8 million.
-It sounds like good idea until
you walk into the bathroom
and you see a squirrel
holding his nuts, you know?
-Hey! Whoa!
♪♪
-Guys, and, finally,
it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ "WeTweet" ♪
♪ "WeTweet" ♪
-Now, welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something that
we should post on Twitter.
I'm gonna show you
five different tweets,
and we're all going to
vote on whether
you like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
You see them there?
I can judge by
the confusion, yep.
Alright, perfect.
You can vote for all of them.
You can vote for none of them.
Whatever you want.
I want you to have fun, okay?
We're gonna see
the results live.
Higgins, Roots,
you have clickers, too?
-I got my clicker.
-Yep, I'm all done.
-You're clicked out.
Alright, here we go.
Whatever tweet gets
the most likes,
we will tweet it out
live on the show
so you can all like it
and "WeTweet" it.
It's a shared experience.
Okay, you guys ready for this?
Okay, the first tweet is...
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is good. The first tweet...
Hmm. Hmm. Lukewarm response.
-No, yeah, lukewarm.
-Lukewarm at best.
Yeah, people are already
done voting.
Immediately, they said, "No."
You can cast your votes,
thumbs up or thumbs down.
They know --
I feel like this one --
-I think they picked
thumbs down.
thumbs down on this one.
[ Drumroll ]
-I thumbs-upped it.
-You thumbs-upped it?
-Yeah.
-I did it just to --
I felt bad for it.
-You felt bad for
the tweet itself?
Oh, I see.
-Yeah. But the votes are in.
Let's see the results.
Here we go.
Oh, not bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That's actually not bad.
That's pretty good.
-Yeah, 135.
-"Let's get brunch," yeah.
11:00 a.m., yeah.
-Hammered, 11:00 a.m.
-Yeah, gotcha. Alright.
Oh, I like this one.
The next one is...
♪♪
It's one of the two.
-Just that little thing.
-It's one of the two.
Either -- I can't --
That thing spins,
you know I got to
spin on that thing.
Also, medical school.
It takes years.
Too much work for me.
Alright, let's see
the results on this one.
I think it's gonna go
pretty well.
Yeah!
-Oh!
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That's good, 183.
-That's pretty good.
-Yeah, that might be
the winner, right there.
But we have three more.
-Really?
-Yeah.
Let's see if you enjoy this one.
This next one's pretty good.
-Oh. Pithy, simple.
♪♪
-I voted -- Yeah.
-You say no? You voted down?
-I voted yes,
'cause I feel like --
Someone's very animated.
They're doing this.
It doesn't help.
-I like that, though.
Then you know they voted.
-And then I just saw an actual
human thumbs-down
from a -- A man in the audience
just gave me a thumbs-down.
Which he's been giving me all
monologue, by the way.
Let's see the results.
Alright. Okay. Wow.
-Ooh! Wow!
-They did not like that.
Steven Spielberg
asked for the "director's cut."
-Come on. That's pretty funny.
-It's pretty funny.
Yeah, that's good.
Next up, we have...
♪♪
"It's gonna be out,
and it's gonna be on."
"I can't even tell.
What is this?"
I can't --"
"Dad, you're blinding
half the restaurant."
Alright. There you go.
What do you
think about this, Tariq?
-Uh, yeah, I think it's probably
gonna be half and half.
-Half and half?
-You said it's gonna be evenly
split, yes or no.
-You think it's gonna be 50/50?
-I do. I do.
-That's impossible.
-That's insane.
-I do.
I think it's gonna be 50/50.
Fight me!
-No, he's saying 70/30.
-Okay, 70/30. I'll say 55/45.
-Oh, there you go!
-Oh! Now!
-It changed a little bit.
Let's check out
the results on this one.
[ Drumroll ]
-Oh!
Oh, snap! Oh, snap!
♪♪
Oh, my God!
Oh, my God! Oh, my God!
Tariq got burned.
-No, that's exactly
what I meant.
-You meant 195.
-That was almost
a knockout punch right there.
-Yeah.
-That's got to be the winner.
Everyone votes for
this one just because --
-195?
-It's almost unheard of.
That will be the one that we
tweet, unless this one --
unless this one is,
like, an avalanche.
-Is this the last one?
-This is the last one,
but I don't know.
[ Drumroll ]
What was the other one?
What did we all just like?
-"Phone on, light on."
-Which one?
-Dad with the light.
-Dad, menu, QR code.
-Oh, yeah. Dad, flash--
Yeah, we can all relate to that.
-It's more of a truism
and funny.
That's what makes it funny,
'cause it's kinda true.
-Yeah, I like that one.
-Yeah.
-That's a good one,
so let's see.
That, I think,
is gonna be the winner.
-I think it's the winner,
but who knows?
-Yep.
-We got one more.
-We have one more. Here we go.
-Tariq, what do you think
this one is gonna be?
-I think this last one's
the winner.
-Okay.
-Yep.
-Last one is...
♪♪
-Oh.
-Wow! That's a stealth one.
You're gonna vote no
just to burn --
just 'cause you like
the other one.
-You know you agree, man.
-Still moving.
-Thumbs up.
-Everyone agrees.
-I don't know, man.
I think "dad flashlight"
takes it.
-You know what?
You don't even want to
go to this one.
-I'm tired of being the peach
of your jokes over here.
-Let's see the results.
-Let's see it.
[ Drumroll ]
-Oh! Oh, my God!
-Yes. You felt that.
It did well. It did well.
"Dad's flashlight"
is the winner, right there.
So now I'm gonna post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a WeTweet, and enjoy.
We have a great show tonight.